AfD gains strongly in the east
and continues its upward trend nationwide.
According to a recent survey,
the AfD leads
in the east of Germany
with 8 percent points ahead of the Union.
Compared to the federal elections 2,021
records the AfD
an increase of 13 comma 1 percent,
while the CDU gained only 6 points 9 percent.
Especially the parties of the traffic light coalition
are punished,
with the chancellor SPD losing 12 commas 1 percent.
The Greens keep it easy in the east,
while the FDP slips to 4 percent.
With regard to the state elections 2,024 in 3 OST
States of Saxony,
Thuringia,
Brandenburg
could the AfD high
make it difficult to form majorities and coalitions.
Remarkable is,
that the AfD has never yet been the strongest force
was in a major election,
but this could change in the next year.
The nationwide Forza survey shows,
that the AfD
also rises to 22 percent at the federal level,
while The Greens lose one percentage point.
The SPD remains unchanged at 14 percent,
the Union leads with 30 percent
and the FDP achieves 5 percent.
At 4 percent,
the left could
miss the entry into the Bundestag.